I'm watching this uh 49ers game yeah
dude brutal here's here's you can shoot
down this statement you can say I'm the
biggest [__] idiots but I just need
to understand at the playoff level
mhm do you need your quarterback to be
able to put the game in his hands to win
yes to win a Super Bowl unless you have
a historically great defense yeah and
that's I can literally think of one
exception which
RAV like 2000 you need at some point you
will need your quarterback and even the
San Francisco quarterback second half he
started making plays but there were
moments where he put the team on his
back yeah there were a couple runs he
made some good throws um throws on the
run which is a big thing throws on but
and also I think uh obviously um Jared G
there was a couple like yeah he missed a
couple long passes that would have and
even like the interception like bouncing
off of the [__] face mask unb that
was very lucky Brock party's part I
guess what I'm trying to say is like you
start to see it also with Patrick
Mahomes where there are points in a game
yeah where he will put the team on his
back he will just make the play he'll do
the extra thing which you don't think
can really happen with football because
there's so many guys on the field right
you're like oh one guy can't really
change the game maybe one guy can change
the game when he's the quarterback and
that needs to happen in playoffs he
literally touches the ball every
offensive play yeah there's almost no
plays where he doesn't get the ball so
he has the ability even on a hand off
he's touching it but every time he
passes 40 times a game he can change the
entire game a receiver gets eight that's
expected then so then then the question
I have is because there's that great
clip that was going out with like Odell
Beckham Jr sitting on the sideline with
Lamar Jackson you see this and he
goes I'm GNA [__] it up but he um he he
said something like uh you know like hey
when you when you let loose or when you
get on your feet you change the dynamic
of the game I think he was almost like
imploring him to like run the ball
and maybe that's Odell going hey we need
you to put us on your back absolutely
put on the fcking cape which I've seen
you do many times just do it you got
this get out of your head go be you so
it's yeah it's really so that can you
win a Super Bowl with a bad quarterback
yeah again if you have like the the
Ravens Trent dord wasn't bad but they'll
call him a game manager I looked up the
worst quarterback dord was the first one
first one and he wasn't but Hasselbeck
didn't win a Super Bowl trenord they
lost to I think the Steelers or
something but Trent dord wasn't awful he
can't at that point we call you a game
manager like just don't throw
interceptions don't hurt us just get us
down the field once or twice if we kick
field goals every time that's fine our
defense is not giving up any points
we'll win so the idea is the defense is
going to put the offense in great
positions to score in other words like
pin them down on the yeah we're not
giving up any points beyond that we're
just not you're not going to score on us
you're not going to get in field goal
range you're not going to get into
touchdown you're not so six points we
win exactly but so basically you're
going to force them to punt and if
you're in an advantageous field position
because of those punts get 30 yards yeah
if you start on the 50 get 30 yards we
kick a field ABS got it got it we'll
turn we'll get you turnovers we'll do
everything and again that is the
probably the greatest defense ever top
two for sure so then what happened to
Lamar dude I so here's the thing I don't
as I'm as I'm realizing I'm 40 I don't
want to like sit there and have just
[__] on young kids playing a game that
are like I do think he puts too much
pressure on himself okay what happens
and I think this happened with the
Cowboys quarterback your first few
playoff games if you don't win this
narrative starts to form especially if
you're as good as Lamar Jackson is Lamar
Jackson is so [__] good so this
pressure every time he underperformed in
the playoffs doubles triples quadruples
and now it's like he can't [__]
Escape it and I felt watching the game
he's trying to force it he's like trying
to hit home runs dude he had an insane
touchdown the first touchdown but I felt
like he kept going for these long passes
and not just hey trust your instincts
[__] run if you need to run hey
here's an 8- yard underneath pass take
that take that take that uh you know i'
I'd like to make a comparison to uh one
of the greatest sports ever which which
sport paddle uh okay I absolutely sucked
to I got my ass kicked but I was playing
with a guy who was basically like a pro
he's like the teacher and he was making
some mistakes they were my faults in a
way yeah and basically what's happening
is he's trying to finish every point he
can because I'm on his team so if he
just gets it over and they get it back
to me that might be their point yeah
they can kind of score on me whenever
the [__] they want so I saw him making
some mistakes and then I and I realized
oh he has to take more chances that's
probably what Lamar is doing he's going
I can't let this narrative build about
me I got to drive the ball down the
field this is the Chiefs Patrick Mahomes
is on the other side that's adding to oh
that's the other thing that's your
rivalry this is the darling of the
League this is the person that everybody
thinks I wouldn't even yeah that's true
also I'm thinking this guy's so [__]
good if I don't put if I don't get seven
every time I don't know if we beat them
we got to get touchdowns we got to hit
home runs that's the only way you beat a
quarterback that that's that great yeah
uh and even like to tie it to what I
always tie everything to Comedy have you
ever gone on stage and been like I
really want to do well instead of just I
want to have fun when you start focusing
on how well you're going to do and how
hard you're going to going to kill it
almost always is worse than if you're
like hey let me just have fun do my
[__] thing trust my instincts
everything will work out yeah and I feel
that's happening with Dak Prescott I
feel it's happening with Lamar and again
I'm not trying to be critical of
children when I'm 40 yeah and they did
this at a higher level than I could ever
dream of but I do as like a an older guy
watching younger kids I'm like ah [__]
you're you're putting too much pressure
on yourself and you're trying to do too
much that's how I feel now you guys all
watch that San Francisco game oh yeah I
was so brutal man no you didn't watch it
okay oh God and again I'm watching the
game listen I'm a casual okay this kid
pry yeah made Big Boy decisions in the
second half yeah and I was just
incredibly impressed like he he could
have checked down he could have thrown
out of B like there are moments where
instead of running for [__] 12 15
yards getting that first down he could
have done the safer thing to do yeah he
made the decision in that moment in the
biggest game of his life this is a
rookie second year Oh I thought this is
second year but the last pick in the
draft they literally call that pick Mr
Irrelevant cuz they never go it's
there's like 30 picks he's number 232 or
whatever the last possible pick he I was
just like impressed by the walls of it
yeah I was too and I'm I was never a
Believer and in the first half I was
feeling Vindicated I was like dude
everybody's talking about this guy's MVP
I don't get it yeah but in the second
half I think Troy Amman also said a
thing where he said like I just knew in
the playoffs things slow down at a
certain point every game the defense is
not going to be this excited coming at
me this hard it's going to slow down at
a certain point they're going to get a
little tired the crowd is going to calm
down and that's that's all you just got
to wait that out and I don't think he
did it wittingly but I think Brock Brock
Bry waited that out the whole Detroit
Title Wave of energy and ferocity and
all that he ended up just kind of
waiting it out and then as things
settled down they got a little momentum
he made plays when he needed to and they
won and you have to give him credit I
don't know if he can beat Mahomes yeah
so what happens in the Super Bowl San
Francisco I think is the better team I
think just because they have so many
weapons on offense and their defense
isn't it KC's defense is really good
this year yeah but I just know the
reputation of San Francisco's defense at
least but they're also going up against
the greatest i' you think he'll be the
greatest ever I think he Brady's career
was so long I don't you can't say
Mahomes is the greatest now but I've
never seen quarterback played this well
ever at like in just a window of time
what does that [__] I always say about
me I'm a prisoner of the moment moment
yeah all sports play bro we are such
prison like literally the greatest a
year ago we were saying that Tom Bray is
the greatest athlete of all time like
nobody will ever touch this and we're
already saying that there's another
quarterback that is potentially better
could be potentially yeah he's not there
yet I will say this I've never seen it
in five years who knows what he's going
to do that's part of Brady's greatness
is 20 years or whatever being amazing
right now no one's ever played
quarterback this well and I don't think
that's a crazy opinion at all in my
lifetime not even close he can do
everything big boner Madness blue chew
has got your back same active ingredient
that's inside by Agra seis but this is
The Chew okay it's one that we rock with
and this is the one you're going to keep
your girl satisfied with satisfied no no
no no you're going to keep your girl
shaking she's going to be shaking inner
thighs getting the workout okay way
better than any of those classes she's
doing this is The Chew okay same active
ingredients that's inside viager SE Alis
I'm just telling you but this is The
Chew okay you're going to get your first
month free first month free all you got
to do is pay $5 shipping you go to
blu.com use the promo code flagrant you
get your first month free you pay the $5
shipping and you enjoy let's get back to
the show do you think the Lions lost was
a coaching mistake I do and I love that
coach oh you don't like going for it on
Fourth I I love going for it on Fourth I
do but I actually I should be working at
Madden bro I don't think I ever I don't
think that ever didn't work yeah and i'
love playing the game like that and I
think I heard somebody say uh he had a
really good point he was like Detroit
had such a stink of losing I think he is
trying to get rid of in their play The
Players Minds we're not losers we go for
the win we go for it on fourth down we
go for two-point conversions we're
[__] winners we go for the kill but I
remember texting my friend there was
another fourth down where he decided to
kick a field goal the end of the first
half at the end of the first half he
kicked a field goal took the safe three
points it was fourth and goal with like
10 seconds left in the first half I was
telling my friend I think I might go for
this because if you get it you [__]
break San Francisco Spirit the risk is
if you don't get it San Francisco at
half time it was 24 it was uh 217 2 you
get a touch down is 287 and San
Francisco's got to mentally and I was
like dude I would and now at the end he
kicked the field goal and I was like
that's fair cuz if he didn't get it you
gave San Francisco a ton of Life they
get the ball back but I do remember
texting him it was fourth and three
Detroit is up 2410 San Francisco just
kicked a field goal they could kick a
very safe field goal or go for it maybe
it was fourth and two but I texted my
friend I would not go for it here I
would kick the field goal cuz they just
scored three you need to show San
Francisco you can get your little three
points we're going to keep matching you
yeah they went for it didn't get it then
San Francisco had the luckiest [__]
deep pass I've ever seen in my life
frankly but once they got that I knew I
was like oh it's over it's they're still
down 247 they're still down 2410 at that
point but I was like they're going to
score they're on the two yard line
moment and the momentum is so crazy now
you just [__] and he there was a losing
decision and I love that coach I think
he's great but that was a losing
decision D they always say that [__]
about uh and it was even in that
quarterback documentary on Netflix the
show I watched parts of it momes is so
[__] cool it was cool to just see all
of them but like they really harp on how
much time they're spending studying yeah
and I didn't believe it until I saw
Holmes's body mahomes's body mahomes's
body like there's a picture of mahomes's
body in the locker room yeah and um it
looks uh
studious you know what I mean like like
these guys are Elite athletes looks like
he plays paddle exact that's a paddle B
that is a paddle
body it's so funny we're talking about
and he can run run his ass off this is
an elite athlete so why do quarterbacks
look like this I dude I haven't figured
it out and I know he works he trains
very hard I think they're training in a
very specific way that isn't I need to
look shredded yeah it's like baseball
pitchers you ever see baseball pites
they train they're extremely good at
what they do but it's just like here
down and everything else why are we
wasting it yeah that's pit is it's Mass
moves Mass so the he you are like bigger
the pitcher the longer they are the
taller move the baseball I also thought
about this we were talking to some
football player and he basically said
like if I'm going up against a team that
I know has like big bruising linebackers
I was thinking that he was like I'll add
more weight that week I go what oh I
didn't know he goes yeah I like coming
in a little heavier yeah because I'm
going to have to you know you have to
take Force so physics extra 10 15 lbs of
fat when 300 lb guys are tackling me who
cares I can use that probably so maybe
this protects them a little bit I bet
you this helps being lean and shredded
can probably get more damage done to you
when legitimate 340 lb guys are trying
to tackle you yeah or even just throwing
the ball like just getting we on did you
see that [__] tackle on pie where the
guy basically like slid over his face
yeah yeah yeah that [__] looked
terrifying yeah I think it weirdly kind
of helps explain just one [__] good
hit I think in a high stakes moment can
bring he was already down or something
and then the guy Dove head first over
him like he was sliding into second and
then you
saw yeah but I think a good hit if
you're a quarterback you don't want
[__] concussions but I think one good
shot can kind of take you out of your
head and be like oh I need to be in the
moment I kind of needed that that's a
heck like like like in boxing you get
caught one time and like yeah we're
fighting sparing session yeah you can't
compare a lot of things to boxing
football is war like you said it's War
it's boxing yeah okay so Casey got it I
dude I hope so I obviously hate San
Francisco I'm a cowo you think easy I
hope so they got tail it bro yeah oh
that's true that's true this [__] don't
lose bro that's true yo is Taylor is
Taylor Swift the most emotionally tough
human being on the planet I was thinking
about this exact thing yesterday
actually that's really funny bring that
up explain who gets more scrutinized
she's literally supporting her boyfriend
at his football games she is the busiest
person at that football game yeah
everybody else that organized their
schedule to be there she had to do a lot
more she had to move probably 20 30
people if she goes to the Super Bowl
she's flying from a concert in Tokyo
straight to the Super Bowl to the Super
Bowl she's being the best girlfriend
like all things considered she's
prioritizing this guy in massive moments
in his life while she has a way busier
schedule than even he does and she's
trashed for it if she supports she's
trash if she sings along to the song
she's trash if she gets one thing wrong
in the booth she's trash and she knows
that there is cameras on her the entire
time and no matter what she does if she
[__] up she's trash I think it is I do
think yeah I think it's gotten too far
like here's what I'll say it's it's like
sorry just to just just to clarify what
I'm saying is I'm not saying we should
feel bad I didn't say that I said the
emotional toughness to deal with that is
is admirable I'm not saying that we like
you know she's got a great life she's
got these friends she's got billions of
dollars she could do whatever she wants
she could fly around the world she's you
know she's got her passion she's living
through it but dealing with the
scrutiny and she deals with a lot that's
admirable yeah and here's what I was
going to say I do think it's gotten I
love hating on Taylor but when she's
[__] on the field trying to kiss her
boyfriend after the championship game
and people on the field are yelling at
her you ruin the NFL it's like dude I'm
I'm going to games now I also think a
lot of that hate is a reaction to the
Absurd love that she gets that's a
little bit too much yes of course now
it's kind of an equal and opposite
reaction but still that's when I was
like oh this is like yo yelling at these
things at a person that's just there on
a field that you've ruined a sports
League that you're actually making
hundreds of millions of dollars for it
would drive me [__] crazy yeah I get
where it comes from but it's G if she
didn't show up to any games people would
be like this selfish [__] only cares
about herself she won't support her man
she's just doing this for for clout or
whatever it is yeah it's uh it's
interesting yeah I mean it's it's a
rough like it's a great life she has but
the amount of [__] that she's starting
to get I'm like this is too far yeah
what's the deal with the kicker for the
Ravens and uh Travis Kelce and and
Mahomes like kicking a ship oh yeah this
is a little pregame thing that I thought
people kind of made too big of a deal
about so typically teams from what I
understand warm up on different sides of
the field but also typically kickers
will warm up on both sides of the field
because wind is different depending on
which way you're facing so the Ravens
kicker Justin Tucker who's [__] great
for what it's worth but he's kicking on
in the chief's End Zone and then Patrick
Mahomes and Travis Kelce are like moving
every they're like getting the
placeholders out of there they keep
throwing his football they're like
you're not [__] warming up on our
side which is like shitty I guess but I
also love that bro this is a [__]
championship game we're not here to be
nice and Buddy Buddy didn't Travis say
something specifically on the thought
about it I think he responded he
referenced it where basically he was
like yeah you were intentionally putting
it while we were warming up in like the
quarterback area while we wereing up
yeah like you can come to our side but
you have to like move off to the side
like don't be in the quarterback makes
even more he made it seem like he was
painted to beat his bad guy but it was
really gamesmanship on Justin Tucker's
part and they're just not having exactly
and I wish the Cowboys had players like
that [__] you Moxy yeah like the dude
there's a pregame speech before the
Cowboys game that I'm going to kind of
probably bastard but like the Aaron
Jones the Packers running back I think
it is he's doing the speech to his
teammates he's like we're going to punch
these Front Runners in the mouth they're
going to fold they're not they're not
built like us you're not saying that to
the Chiefs nobody's facing the Chiefs
and it's like they're not built like us
you're going to bully these guys they're
soft you're not saying that you're just
not Patrick Mahomes is a [__] dog
Travis Kel a dog Chris Jones a dog Sam
sne is a dog you're not doing that with
them it's like these are champions and
they're dogs and they fight for Jordan
would have done the same [__] [__] you
[__] warming up on my side [__] out
of here yeah yeah I like that hockey is
great this kind of like no no no this
I'm talking serious bro like the reason
hockey's fun is cuz there's so many like
sort of rules that are unspoken and
they're enforcer rules and things like
this so like that split they they warm
up at the same time and like you do not
cross the line and if your Puck goes
across you can't go get it there's like
little rules like that and if you like
[__] with the goalie on your team that
guy's going to get absolutely yeah
mangled there's like gentlemen's
agreements this happens in baseball a
lot too yeah baseball has it the most
known one is probably the bat flipping
one which they're passed finally now if
you go ahead and flip your bat finally
yeah s of oh really I thought it's still
like a some people I think still take it
poorly but if and it's maybe you're like
there's like a level where it's too much
but they they don't mind the back I
think we talked about this on the Pod
before but it is funny that the single
hardest thing to do in all of sports is
to hit a baseball yeah even harder is to
hit the baseball out of the stadium
whatever that you're you're playing in
and you can't even
celebrate if there was ever a Justified
celebration in sports it's just throwing
the bat up in the air after you did a
miracle football's gotten to the point
and I think you should be allowed to do
it but you recover a fumble the entire
defense runs in the end zone and
celebrates we just landed on the
football when it fell out baseball you
hit you hit a baseball say even if they
don't score yeah dude even you don't
score now youve recover you intercept a
pass whole team celebrates In The End
Zone they all run to the end zone
celebration and it's fun dude we all
love it no touchdown no touchdown just a
turnover turn bro have you seen the
chains turnover Chains No unbelievable
so it's in college and high school and I
think in professional sometimes it's a
massive chain like big iced out like
sort of fake oh yeah this is popularized
by the University of Miami if you if you
catch a interception you get the
turnover chain for the rest of the game
to wear on the sideline it's like
massive it's awesome yeah yeah fire some
culture to it it's fun yeah and baseball
again I think they're starting
baseball's got a bunch right a lot
they're starting to realize they need to
kind of get with the times like they
added a pitch clock so the games are way
faster those are the CH those are the
changes I think that's a great idea also
like the bad flip let them [__] flip
the bad sometimes yeah let them
celebrate there's a lot of rules like
celebrating and [__] like even when
you're running like you're just got to
run fast if you if you jog it's
disrespectful don't down the picture
stared on the pictur disrespectful
that's why bball yeah back in but I felt
like the 90s they let that [__]
Rock